the cores the double net Gibson SG of
course everyone knows that is stairway
to heaven the iconic hit by the rock
band Led Zeppelin it is from their
fourth album which was released in 1971
the record is the fifth selling album of
all time in the United States Led
Zeppelin was formed three years earlier
in 1968 to mark their 50th anniversary
the band is releasing a book tomorrow
called
Led Zeppelin by Led Zeppelin it features
previously unseen photos compiled by the
three surviving members Charlie d'Agata
spoke to guitarist Jimmy Page in an
interview you will only see on CBS this
morning
[Music]
they elevated the rockband
[Music]
to a work of art
so when it came time to launch a book
chronicling 50 years of Led Zeppelin
it seemed fitting that Jimmy Page would
use London's National Portrait Gallery
we got a backstage pass Paige how are
you not only the band's guitarist but
creator and visionary was there a moment
when the four of you got together for
the first time in first couple of times
you thought wow this but the very first
rehearsal that we did very first
rehearsal was here in London in a
rehearsal room where we have maybe an
hour or two hours student we just got
together and we counted one two three
four and we were in and we're all
playing and we just kept extending the
song and jamming on it and by the end of
it I absolutely guarantee that it was a
life-changing experience for everybody
from that point you know everyone knew
that they've never played with musical
equals musical equals without equal
Robert Plant and drummer John Bonham are
just 20 year olds bassist John Paul
Jones 22 and page 24
we're already veteran musicians it's the
first book about Led Zeppelin by Led
Zeppelin an extensive archive of
previously unseen photos handpicked by
the surviving members of the band even
if they were seeing some of them for the
first time you're paying attention to
the music or getting ready to perform
that's right that's right the last thing
in your mind really is well they just
sort of stopped and posed with
photographs and we just get on with
things
the first gig we'll say in Scandinavia
because I was very keen to be able to
have the group playing in front of an
audience before we went in the studio
they would be an album band one classic
at a time from Led Zeppelin one through
1982 s coda
nine studio albums that sold more than
300 million copies around the world one
of the most successful catalogs of the
rock age in recent years pages tried to
keep the Zeppelin in the air presiding
over a series of archive releases
[Music]
by the mid-70s Led Zeppelin had created
every rock band stereotype but back in
1968 Paige's vision was unique I knew
that the way to do it was to have four
musicians that were just you know really
locked in tight and everyone could be
heard on the records and it wasn't just
about one person but the overall but it
meant they could never be Led Zeppelin
without each other
so when drummer John Bonham died in 1980
that meant the end of the band too
in 2007 with Bonhams son Jason on drums
[Music]
Paige plantain Jones regrouped at
London's o2 arena 20 million fans
applied for the 20,000 tickets
[Music]
look I I have learned not to ask you
about Led Zeppelin warming I've seen
what happens when interviewers do yeah
you see the subjects face start to drop
but those fans might not be alone in
missing the magic would you like to see
it well I'd like to look at that video
of us in 11 years ago at the o2 don't
you send that in the celebration day you
said that in the book you said oh what a
marvelous day it was well I'm pretty
consistent as consistent as he's been
since 1968
he created a band that would last little
more than a decade you'll rock and roll
forever for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata London everybody at home is
singing that last work yeah you guys
play the guitars any good every stroke
that ever happened came from Judy yeah
he's amazing he was an amazing session
musician before that yeah